LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back
to Google Developers
Weekly for February 10, 2014.
I'm Louis Gray, and this
is our highlight reel
of what's happening in the
world of Google Developers,
on the set and off.
The big news of the week
comes from a little device.
Chrome Cast is now open to
developers for the Google Cast
SDK.
We have four DevBytes
this week covering
how you can get
started, as well as
special focuses on
developing for Chrome and iOS
in addition to Android.
We then brought in the
analytics team Brian
Kuhn, Lukas Bergstrom,
and Andrew Wales
to learn more about how the
Google Tag Managers data
layer makes implementing
analytics easy.
From Paris, Alexis MP brought
us a pair of interviews,
first with Nicholas Jeffrey
of the Dart team talking
Dart 1.0 for web developers,
and then [INAUDIBLE]
from the Chrome team to talk
Yeoman and other developer
productivity tools.
Then from New York,
Jeff Posnick is back
with the latest tips on
migrating from YouTube data API
version 2 to version 3.
This week, he walks you
through the V3 API calls
needed to subscribe
to a YouTube channel
with live demos using
the API Explorer.
And the Women Tech
Makers crew back.
First, we start with the Gnome
Outreach Program for Women,
helping lady coders get
involved in free and open source
software.
Then, en espanol,
Francisco [INAUDIBLE]
hosted the winners of
Developer Bust 2013,
including three who are
tackling challenges facing women
in tech in their own countries.
Usually hailing from our Tokyo
office, [INAUDIBLE] Suzuki
hosted Google Developer
expert, Atusi Nakamura
here in Mountain View this week.
The pair discussed
Google's App Script API
and developing for App Script.
The event's in Japanese, so have
your Google Translate handy.
From Madrid, Frances Campoy, in
collaboration with the Madrid
GDG, presents the
commonalities and differences
of Go and Python,
specifically talking
about decorators, generators,
concurrency, and more.
And as we've discussed before,
Google's Summer of Code
is a chance for young coders
to shine and for organizations
to be valuable mentors.
Open source maven Cat
Allman hosted Carol Smith,
and talked about
what organizations
interested in applying for
Google's Summer of Code
need to know,
wrapping our events
in the studio for the week.
But there's one more thing.
We know coders are
creative artists.
So now's your
chance to prove it.
Google and the
Barbican in London
are looking for your
art made with code.
If you wow the judges, you
could earn a commission
to join the exhibit alongside
world-renowned creative
artists.
So warm up both
sides of your brain.
And to make sure you
never miss a thing,
from the world of
Google Developers,
subscribe to Google Developers
on YouTube and check out
the GDL schedule at
developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.